soon a huge fire at a north las vegas
recycling center pretty much taken care
of at the moment still burning a little
bit flames and smoke though filled the
valley sky for hours hector mejia is
live right now near commerce and gown
with new details about what started the
fire hector
well investigators believe garbage that
was really hot is what caused this large
fire scene you see right behind us the
good news this afternoon no reports of
injuries right now as you can see crews
are still hosing down hot spots and
they've made significant progress since
five o'clock this morning that's when
the first 911 calls came in
we've learned it only took minutes for
this fire to spread in this video shot
by north las vegas fire department you
see large flames burning around stacks
of cardboard and plastic this is the
republic services recycling center up in
north las vegas and it tore through
several hundred of those tall stacks
investigators believe it all started
outside and spread into the building by
monday afternoon they determined that
what they are calling a hot load was to
blame a truck was delivered
when it off when it drops off the waste
it has
sometimes they have things in there that
catch on fire you saw the fire load that
we had when we got on scene and that
only took minutes for it to extend
because there's not a lot of barrier to
keep the fire from growing we're told
this is mostly an open area warehouse
where garbage mainly recyclables gets
delivered and sorted these bales of
cardboard are the ones that are
typically brought in from local
businesses
and crews tell us they'll be out here
throughout the day as many as 65
firefighters responded to the scene as
you can see still out here and again
they'll be out here throughout the day
reporting live hector mejia 8 news now